the other thing Kevin McCarthy did today
was not just involving going to the
White House and not speaking in complete
sentences that can be understood by
people who uh their native tongue is
English uh he was a prayer breakfast the
the the the the the the Gathering for
prayer and repentance
Tony Perkins joint I guess
and it is a gathering of of Christian
nationalists and radicals and there were
over a dozen members of Congress there
today and I'm going to play I'm going to
play a couple of Clips here one
um
Kevin McCarthy went and actually gave a
prayer at this thing with members of
Congress republicans in Congress before
him doing his father God thing and and
really laying it on thick that he's some
holy devout righteous man of God and uh
give you a flavor for that then let's
move on to Andrew Brunson who's a
Christian nationalist preacher who is
just laying the the bigotry just amping
it up to 11. watch Kevin McCarthy give
his little prayer dear heavenly father
we come before you today
to seek your forgiveness
father we thank you for that forgiveness
we thank you for your love we thank you
for your grace
father I want to lift up these Faith
leaders from across the nation
father I want to thank you that we can
pray and seek your word and seek your
forgiveness in the Museum of the Bible
it's all a bit much look
this is not intended as as a mockery of
religion this is my faith tradition this
is what I grew up in is this this this
flavor of of evangelicalism
ultimately what is white Christian
nationalism
but to parade yourself out
praying to Jesus Christ while
jettisoning any adherence to the
philosophies of the actual man is just I
mean blasphemy comes to mind
sharing a stage the woman off to the
left there on your screen Mary Miller
is someone who has praised Hitler in
speeches right outside the United States
capital
but let's go to Andrew Brunson
who is giving a
just a a wild bigoted screed talking
about us living under and being ruled by
the rainbow flag
it's let's talk about it on the other
side watch this
I believe that we are in danger of
judgment as a nation especially because
we have become the primary corrupter of
the world
and particularly of Youth and children
our government and Corporation is
increasingly March under the rainbow
flag
we bully weaker and poorer countries to
come under that flag our University's
train millions of foreign students who
return to their countries with this
ideology
our social media and entertainment
companies make it attractive they
promote they normalize celebrate
immorality
and there's no escaping them as a
blanket the world
they're Godly mothers and fathers around
the world who fear our influence and
sometimes when I'm in a foreign country
I want to fall in my knees and repent
for what we are doing to these countries
to these people
Jesus said woe to the ones who to the
one who causes others to sin
and he underlines us especially in
relation to the young whoever causes one
of these little ones to sin it would be
better for him if a millstone were hung
around his neck and he were drowned in
the depth of the sea
I hate to break it to you Andrew Brunson
gay people exist
and we're not marching uh our government
and corporations increasingly March
under the rainbow flag
gay people exist
and they are American citizens who have
rights
equal protection
as far as the 14th Amendment of the
Constitution
and for Kevin McCarthy to share the same
stage on the same day within this the
frame of a few minutes as this bigot is
alarming
this is the the political Battle of the
next eight to ten years maybe Beyond
because they're no longer quiet they're
no longer Whispering about being
Christian nationalists and again when
you hear Christian nationalists you
should automatically know that it is
white Christian nationalist because
these same people
who talk about the philosophies of Jesus
they don't want equality for everyone
they don't want equity on a stage
through education or financial
um
assistance in this country
they want to prop up white supremacy
they want to oppress gay people they
want to strip away women's Reproductive
Rights
and if if you don't think that it's
important and you think that I'm just
rambling here about some prayer
breakfast
you need to pay a closer closer
attention to what is taking place
because this has been
a concerted effort a strategic effort
over the course of decades
when the religious right and the the
moral majority of Jerry Falwell
this is what they've led to this is what
they have planned and strategically
worked for over the course of 30 or 40
or 50 years
and they're getting their way they're
winning Roe v Wade was overturned
by a group of fanatical
religious nut bags
who sit on the Supreme Court
and it would be one thing if it was just
Andrew Brunson some guy you've probably
never heard of
but it's not just Andrew Brunson
Randy Weber
republican from Texas actually gave a
prayer here I'm going to play it for you
where he's sobbing and weeping about all
the millions of babies that we've killed
he's he's begging God for forgiveness
to put America back on the right path
worshiping you we've taken God out of
the classroom
ignoring
the First Amendment of the Constitution
that Congress shall make no law
respecting an establishment of religion
but they want Jesus in the classroom
talk to little Muslim kids or little
Jewish kids or little atheist kids
so it's not just Andrew Brunson it is
members of Congress who have the power
to vote on legislation
who are there too
who are who are luxuriating in the
bigotry
watch Randy Weber father you say in your
word that unless the Lord watches over
the city
The Watchmen stay awake in vain
Lord we are a nation without a Rudder a
drift father we think we're so smart
we've kicked you out of schools we've
kicked prayer out we've kicked the Ten
Commandments and we've replaced the you
with drug-sniffing dogs with armed
police officers with metal detectors
Lord forgive us
father we've trampled on holy matrimony
Lord God we have killed so many babies
and we call them a choice and I remember
in Deuteronomy 30 19 Moses called Israel
to choose life so that we in all of our
descendants could live Lord our
descendants aren't living we're killing
them
and we're
father you also say in your word
that the borrow is slave to the lender
and Lord we have totally forgotten your
word and your precepts and we're 33
trillion dollars in debt father we think
we're so smart but Lord please forgive
us
please please put America back on the
right path to worshiping you father I
ask this through the blood of the Lamb
Jesus Christ amen
come on man
that guy gets to vote on legislation
that guy has an impact on your everyday
life
sobbing and wailing and gnashing of
teeth
weeping that he cannot
uh rule your life with his Christoph
fascism
that we've trampled on holy matrimony
because dudes can get married now with
what
it's all it's all
dangerous that will impact your life at
some point you might not feel it now but
in eight or ten years if this is ignored
we're going to be in a really
tough spot
once again I am Jesse dollar Moore I'd
love to see you follow me on social
media at dollarmore on Twitter Instagram
Tick Tock just at dollar more look for
me here on YouTube uh just search my
name dollar more daily I host uh just
about every day
and I host a twice weekly podcast called
I doubt it that you could find anywhere
that you find podcasts
see you there